soyez prêts pour tenter un coup de force
mais pourquoi pas il en a mené des coups
de force marcel campion des actions pour
défendre les siens les forains des coups
médiatiques musclées parfois à la limite
de la légalité
le prochain est de taille conquérir la
mairie de paris
paris une ville avec laquelle marcel
campion a des relations disons tendu
[Musique]
le premier coup de force médiatique pour
marcel campion c'était en 1985 au jardin
des tuileries 350 véhicules de forains
envahissent les allées une action contre
la mairie de paris et le ministère de la
culture
le but obtenir le droit d'exploiter le
lieu comme il le faisait dix ans plus
tôt le savons que nos manèges rises
pourquoi parce que nous nous sommes déjà
installés avec des autorisations de
ministères sur ces mêmes emplacements
alors tout ça c'est de la mauvaise foi
pour attirer l'attention ce jour là
marcel campion a appelé yves mourousi
grande figure de la télé à l'époque car
c'est aussi ça la méthode campion un
réseau médiatique et politique qui lui
vaut le surnom de parrain du lobby
forains on arrive avec la fête et on
devient les rois du village
marcel roi de la fête et défenseurs des
forains campion provocateur grandes
gueules à paris le symbole de la
discorde autour du personnage c'est sa
grande roue l'emblématique roues sur la
place de la concorde
à l'origine elle devait simplement
rester jusqu'au passage à l'an 2000
ça nouveau monument à paris quand on
essaiera de conserver je crois sur paris
sauf qu'en 2002 après proposition
d'autres emplacements proposition que
marcel campion a refusé la ville annonce
la fin de la grande roue ils menacent
alors la mer ici qu'on affrontera les
forces de police et qu'on fera la
guérilla sur la place de la concorde
s'il le faut et on verra bien ce qui va
arriver
disparue puis revenu puis définitivement
mis à l'arrêt en 2018
depuis marcel campion fait parler de lui
pour ses propos polémiques
il a qualifié la maire de paris anne
hidalgo de dérangé mentalement et selon
lui toute la ville est gouverné par des
homos pris dans la tourmente marcel
campion a décidé d'arrêter toutes ces
activités foraines reste à voir ce que
donnera son avenir politique
[Musique]